bah-ha Spinoza was a 17th century Dutch
philosopher who tried to reinvent
religion moving it away from something
based on superstition and ideas of
direct divine intervention to being a
discipline that was going to be far more
impersonal quasi scientific and yet also
at times serenely consoling baho the
word means blessed in Hebrew was born in
the Jewish quarter of Amsterdam in 1632
a thriving center of Jewish Commerce and
thought his ancestors were Sephardic
Jews who had fled the Spanish Peninsula
following the catholic inspired
expulsion of 1492
ah-ho-ho studious highly intelligent
child received an intensely traditional
jewish education he went to the local
Jewish school the yeshiva and followed
all the Jewish High Holidays and rituals
but gradually he began to distance
himself from the faith of his ancestors
although I have been educated from
boyhood in the accepted beliefs
concerning Scripture he later wrote with
characteristic caution I have felt bound
in the end to embrace other views his
fully fleshed out views were to be
expressed in his great work
the ethics written entirely in Latin and
published in 1677 in the ethics Spinoza
directly challenged the main tenets of
Judaism in particular and organized
religion in general God is not a person
who stands outside of nature there is no
one to hear our prayers or to create
miracles or to punish us for misdeeds
there is no afterlife man is not God's
chosen creature the Bible was only
written by ordinary people
God is not a craftsman or an architect
and or is he a king or a military
strategist who calls for believers to
take up the holy sword God doesn't see
anything nor does he expect anything he
doesn't judge he doesn't even reward the
virtuous with a life after death every
representation of God as a person is a
projection of the imagination and
everything in the traditional liturgical
calendar is pure superstition and
mumbo-jumbo however despite all this
remarkably Spinoza did not declare
himself an atheist he insisted that he
remained a staunch defender of God God
plays an absolutely central role in
Spinoza's ethics
but it isn't anything like the God who
haunts the pages of the Old Testament
Spinoza's God is holy impersonal and
indistinguishable from what we might
variously call nature or existence or a
world soul God is the universe and its
laws God is reason and truth God is the
animating force in everything that is
and can be he is not in time and he
cannot be individuated Spinoza writes
whatever is is in God and nothing can
exist or be conceived without God
throughout his text Spinoza was keen to
undermine the idea of prayer in prayer
an individual appeals to God to change
the way the universe works
but Spinoza argues that this is entirely
the wrong way around the task of human
beings is to try to understand how and
why the universe works the way it does
and then accept it rather than protest
at the workings of existence by sending
little messages up into the sky as
Spinoza put it beautifully but rather
caustically whosoever loves God cannot
strive that God should love him in
return in other words only a deeply
distorted and infantile narcissism would
lead someone at once to believe in God
and then to imagine that this God would
take an interest in bending the rules of
existence to improve his or her life in
some way Spinoza was deeply influenced
by the philosophy of the Stoics of
ancient Greece and Rome they had argued
that wisdom lies not in protest against
how things are but in continuous
attempts to understand the ways of the
world and then bow down peacefully to
necessity Seneca Spinoza's favorite
philosopher had compared human beings to
dogs on a leash being led by the
necessities of life in a range of
directions the more one pulls against
what's necessary the more one is
strangled and therefore the wise must
always endeavour to try to understand
ahead of time how things are for example
what love is like or how politics works
and then change their direction
accordingly so as not to be strangled
unnecessarily it is this kind of stoic
attitude that constantly pervades
Spinoza's philosophy to understand God
traditionally means studying the Bible
another holy text but Spinoza now
introduces another idea the best way to
know God is to understand how
life and the universe work it through a
knowledge of psychology philosophy and
the Natural Sciences that one comes to
understand God in traditional religion
believers ask special favors of God
Spinoza proposes instead that we should
understand what God wants and we can do
so in one way above all by studying
everything that is by reasoning we can
accede to a divine eternal perspective
Spinoza made a famous distinction
between two ways of looking at life we
can either see it Edgar istic Lee from
our limited point of view as he put it
subspecies or s yonus under the aspect
of time or we can look at things
globally and eternally subspecies
eternity artists under the aspect of
eternity our nature means that we'll
always be divided between the two
sensual life pulls us towards a time
bound partial view but our reason and
intelligence can give us unique access
to another perspective it can quite
literally allow us and here Spinoza
becomes beautifully lyrical to
participate in eternal totality normally
we call bad whatever is bad for us and
good whatever increases our power and
advantage but for Spinoza to be truly
ethical means rising above such local
concerns it might all sound forbidding
but Spinoza envisaged his philosophy as
a route to a life based on freedom from
guilt from sorrow from pity or from
shame happiness involves aligning our
will with that of the universe the
universe God has its own projects and
it's our task to understand rather than
rail against these the free person is
one conscious of the necessities that
compel us all Spinoza writes the wise
man the person who understands how and
why things are possesses eternally true
complacency of spirit needless to say
these ideas got Spinoza into a very deep
trouble he was excommunicated from the
Jewish community of Amsterdam in 1656
the rabbi's issued a rich known as Asher
M against the philosopher it went by the
decree of the angels and by the command
of the holy men we excommunicate expel
curse and Damned Bojorquez by noza
with all the curses which are written in
the book of law curse it be he by day
and cursed be he by night
curse it Behe when he lies down and
cursed be he when he rises up Spinoza
was forced to flee Amsterdam and
eventually settled in the hague where he
lived quietly and peacefully as a lens
grinder and private tutor till his death
in 1677 Spinoza's work was largely
forgotten down the ages Hegel took an
interest as it Vidkun Stein and several
other 20th century philosophers but from
many perspectives Spinoza's work
constitutes a warning about failures of
philosophy the ethics is one of the
world's most beautiful books it contains
a calming perspective restoring take on
life it replaces the God of superstition
with a wise and consoling pantheism and
yet Spinoza's work failed utterly to
convince any bit of you to abandon
traditional religion and to move towards
a rationalist why system of belief the
reasons are in a way simple and banal
Spinoza failed to understand
like so many philosophers before in
sense that what leads people to religion
isn't just reason but far more
importantly emotion belief fear and
tradition people stick with their
beliefs because they like the ritual the
communal meals the yearly traditions the
beautiful architecture the music and the
lovely language read out in synagogue or
Church Spinoza's ethics arguably
contains a whole lot more wisdom than
the Bible but because it comes without
any of the Bible supporting structure it
remains a marginal work studied here and
there universities in the West while the
traditional religion that Spinoza
thought outmoded in the 1670s continues
to thrive and convince people if we're
ever to replace traditional beliefs we
must remember just how much religion is
helped along by ritual tradition art and
a desire to belong all things that
Spinoza despite his great wisdom ignored
at his peril in his bold attempt to
replace the Bible
you